former president Donald Trump is in your
news feeds this morning for suggesting
parts of the U.S Constitution should be
terminated and that puts some
Republicans in the hot seat for failing
to condemn that remark Robert Costa is
in Washington with this story for us Bob
good morning Good morning Tony the
former president's post comes as the
Republican party is still dealing with
the Fallout from that dinner Trump had
with white nationalist Nick Fuentes and
the rapper formerly known as Kanye West
who has continually made anti-semitic
comments that dinner antrums post
present a reckoning for his party about
its future
it's the oath of office every president
takes preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States the
Constitution of the United States but
former president Trump is now taking aim
at this founding document opposed from
Trump suggesting the possible
termination of parts of the Constitution
and a redo of the 2020 election Drew
sharp condemnation from Democrats
calling him out of control and dangerous
some Republicans also critical I
certainly don't uh endorse that language
or that sentiment but any political
cause for Trump remains unclear as
others are taking a wait and see
approach I will support whoever the
Republican nominee is and I just don't
think that at this point he'll be able
to get there Trump has kept up the
steady drum beat of false statements
about the 2020 election long after his
own officials told him it was not stolen
I made it clear I did not agree with the
idea of saying the election was stolen
Trump's latest comments were in response
to a report by journalist Matt taibi
that showed Twitter employees
deliberating in October 2020 about how
to handle a New York Post article about
a laptop belonging to Hunter Biden
President Biden's son taibi also
reported both the Biden campaign and the
Trump White House communicated with
Twitter about content this all comes As
Trump faces multiple federal and state
investigations and as the house is
January 6 committee prepares to issue a
sweeping report that will shine a light
on Trump's conduct during the attack on
the capitol but this report could be the
basis in your view for a prosecution I I
think that it could be Donald Trump was
a guy who just would not take no for an
answer from the American people and set
about to overthrow an election speaking
to Republican sources it's clear that
many of Trump's possible 2024 Rivals are
now remaining quiet wondering if Trump's
Campaign Will fizzle out or if he will
face legal headaches that could derail
him but as we saw six years ago that
hope among some Republicans that Trump
will fade away is often dashed Tony yeah
the American people will decide Bob
thank you very much